so your fight with jake paul
looking back you have a had a little bit
of time now
uh how would you analyze that fight
uh
well i mean the fight specifically i got
cracked with an overhand right so i mean
it kind of sucks
um i would say
you know this is why everyone's like i i
don't i really don't care um and
everyone's like why did you make it
turns your reputation it's like well i
wanted to do it i had an enjoyable time
training and in the build up obviously i
wasn't skillful enough to to get to win
but if i even even despite the fact that
i know it's going to have what happened
if someone asked me to do it again i
probably would have done it again you
know and so the way i was thinking about
when i was deciding whether to do it or
not because i got the offer it's like
okay is this money it can change my life
yeah it could right it's
not gonna double my net worth but it's
gonna add significantly make my life
easier number two is like when i was in
high school we used to do boxing matches
for free just because we thought it was
fun when we didn't have something going
on friday night me and my buddies would
get together and we had some boxing
goals in my basement and we'd punch each
other in the head so it's like for
something i think is enjoyable nothing
to pay me a whole bunch of money
yeah sure i'll do it
would you
do you think if you got the rematch if
you did the rematch would you
what are the odds you win okay well it's
not probably not very good i think he's
pretty good actually and i'm not very
good now
at a low point for me because uh so when
i started training for that i was like
215 pounds which is the heaviest out of
bed i came off my hip surgery i
literally
like when i said
yes like i'll do it like i had literally
started working out like the week before
for the first time in my you know since
the surgery because i wasn't able to do
anything
so could i could i perform better yeah
but now after watching him box tyler i'm
like if you ask me ben can you be tyron
probably probably not no i don't think i
can be tyron so
boxing yeah so my chances of beating him
you know and
watching that card it's like damn like
it can't be fun to box someone who i
know sucks so i know it can beat that
that's what would be fun you know
because like they're training their
preparation was fun but then obviously i
got my butt kicked up so that sucked
you